what's up guys and gals Vincent oshana
here at valuetainment I am standing with
Shane winnings that's probably one of
the best last names I've heard all day
probably in my life uh he is a United
States Army veteran uh got out became a
cop and now he's a traveling preacher
Shane thank you for for for being here
and could you just please tell everybody
about a little bit about yourself yeah I
mean I'm 32 you know I'm married that's
probably one of the best decisions I've
made was getting married I've got a son
but yeah you know I I
I I turned down this life of making over
100 Grand and all these things as a cop
because God told me he wanted me to
preach his word and so I've been doing
that for the last two years and man it's
been the most fulfilling time of my life
and the fruit that I've seen has been
undeniable so I'm gonna keep doing this
until I die well uh was there a moment
Shane like was there like a defining
moment from being comfortable making the
money what what was it was it something
in society was it a was an actual call
from God what would you feel like that
moment was where he turned everything
around and and went for God yeah well I
mean you know being in the military but
you have near-death experiences whether
it's in combat or I almost was murdered
in 2020 as a cop and so you have these
sobering moments where things get more
clear but there was this time in 2021
where you know my Ministry online was
growing because I started preaching on
social media during the lockdowns and
God spoke to me one day and he said
you'll never work another day as a cop
and it kind of caught me off guard and I
had this vision of myself as a
missionary to America because how many
people know that America needs help too
it's not just third world countries like
we need the gospel and I begin to weep
because I knew God was speaking to me
and so when God speaks I want him to
know I take him seriously and so I
immediately put my two weeks in at work
we put our house up for sale and we've
been running hard ever since and your
wife the your wife is 100 she's on I'm
I'm assuming she's a Christian too
because that takes a lot yeah I married
the right girl so I I talked to her we
prayed she felt peace about it and so we
went for it so so and so Shane you're
traveling right now you just you just go
and just preach the word of God from
state to state you go uh overseas what's
the what's the story with that yeah so
right now I feel really called to
America
um when I first started I was just
traveling and preaching in parks and
Fields and Gathering people from social
media but now you know I get booked by
Churches or or events like this I'm
speaking tomorrow morning I'm on a tour
with Sean foyt if you've heard of him
we're doing a nationwide tour they're
doing States right now but I can't be
there because I'm preaching here so it's
God's just been filling the schedule and
it's been amazing uh how how big do you
think uh God religion is going to pray
play a part in this upcoming 2024
election I think it's going to be huge
you know there's a lot of Christians
that are praying for justice in so many
areas you know they feel like we
experience a lot of injustices over the
last few years and so people are hoping
that you know we have Fair elections and
that we have the right people getting
elected that represent us not their own
interests you know even in the Old
Testament you see when you've got Kings
and judges that are selfish the people
suffer and the Bible says that when
someone who's evil or someone who is bad
towards God when they're in places of
power the people groan and I think we've
groaned over the last few years and so
people are praying let's get the right
person in office to represent us we know
not everything is fixed by one person
but we can start heading that direction
gotcha and so and Donald Trump I'm
assuming that you're going to vote for
Donald Trump I'm actually voting for
Donald uh Trump as well I feel like this
Administration Shane they've they've
straight off the path I think just
Americans just as a society we're we're
off the path I think
you know what they're teaching the kids
in schools they're pushing this ideology
the lgbtq movement the CRT thing do you
think do you think that's going to play
a big part in the in the election all
that all the LGBT stuff and the and the
critical race theory in schools yeah a
thousand percent I mean you can see with
even Bud Light what happens when you try
to appeal to the minority when you try
to appeal to the one percent you go
broke so politically now that you know
we have the people in office that we do
and they're making these massive
statements to appeal to the one percent
I think the 99 are going to speak very
loudly come election day I think so and
I said this in an earlier uh interview
we spoke about it earlier that is a war
spiritually you know
ideology all that stuff and it's other
you have to pick which one you want to
be you're going to sit back or you're
going to get involved right yeah you
know there's a there's a statement that
the Air Force Academy has that says I
won't lie chill or steep lie uh steal or
cheat or tolerate anyone who does and
that second part has always struck me as
you know so uh weighty because you might
say well I don't steal but if you see
someone doing it you'll stay quiet we're
living in a day where we're seeing
corruption and we're seeing evil things
taking place and it's not good enough to
just point it out you have to take a
stand and like you said you have to pick
a side and uh you know this is a great
time to be a Christian because we know
what we stand for and uh the light can
only shine brightest in the darkness and
so the darker it gets the brighter we
shine and I'm happy to be a Christian I
agree and because we're talking about
this the other side the the negative
side they don't have a recruitment
problem they don't have a problem with
people signing up because people people
are waning in line line to this fight
and you touched on the uh the corruption
and everything we've been seeing for the
past couple years FBI you know
intertwined with Twitter shunning you
know shutting up our voices cheating on
the election the real collusion was not
letting people speak with the hunter
Biden uh laptop and all the all the
January 6 and all that nonsense they uh
just yesterday they uh Secret Service
concluded that the cocaine found they
have no idea who it is they have no
investigation what are your thoughts
when it comes to that corruption uh
about that type of topic you know what I
just generally don't believe anything
that the government says and my life's
been pretty awesome since I started
doing that so you know whatever dude we
all know that where it came from yeah
everybody everybody knows like we're not
stupid like if you at Chris Christie's
house and you saw and you found cookie
crumbs you wouldn't be like who's whose
are these you know it's Christie's you
know what I mean it's like don't don't
lie to the public but it's like but but
Shane they're getting away with anything
that they want Hunter Biden all the the
Father the the whatever I feel like
they're protecting evil I say this Eve
evil is kind of winning and there needs
to be a shift what do you think you know
the Bible talks about this where it
might feel like evil is winning but
there's gonna come a day where no one
gets away with anything and so that's my
job as a preacher and we're talking
about this I care about the human soul
and so I try to provoke people to this
place of like hey there's there's
something happening after this life like
all the decisions you make you might be
fooling everyone else but when you're
standing before God he's not going to be
fooled and so I get I try to get people
to care and think about their eternity
so that they make good decisions and so
that they follow Jesus and so my comfort
in all the evil that's being gotten away
with is that there's going to be
Vengeance one day the Lord says
vengeance is mine and I trust him yeah
and and you nailed it and we spoke about
it earlier uh Shane God bless you thank
you for your service both both veteran
both cop thank you for preaching the
word of God and if you want to tell
everybody where they can find you and
and uh just your your answer Grandma
you're a preacher or you have a website
absolutely yeah shanewinnings.com
everything's on there you can find me on
Instagram at the same name or YouTube
and then I have a podcast called
pursuing Jesus which will really equip
people to walk out what we're talking
about and uh yeah and we spoke about
this everybody we all have something in
common everybody in this building
everybody in the world tall short male
female gay straight we all have an
expiration date we're all gonna die so
stop worrying about the nonsense love
each other love God love your neighbor
and all work out Shane thank you so much
for being here bro God bless you and uh
we're we're here at valuetainment thank
you
foreign
[Music]